es oficial el reino unido está viviendo
hasta ahora su día más caluroso en la
historia la agencia de meteorología
británica ha reportado una temperatura
máxima provisional de 40.2 grados
alcanzada en las afueras del aeropuerto
de heathrow uno de los más importantes
el más grande de londres y uno de los
más importantes del mundo pero las
temperaturas pueden llegar hasta los 42
43 grados en las próximas horas por eso
es que esta temperatura es provisional
en londres hasta ahora reportamos 38
grados de temperatura está una de las
metrópolis más vibrantes del mundo por
lo menos aquí en el sur de la ciudad las
calles no están desiertas desoladas pero
hay muchísima menos gente en la calle
por supuesto por lo fuerte que está
haciendo el sol a esta hora y es que
esta ola de calor que está azotando no
solo al reino unido sino también en
general a europa está causando varios
traumatismos las clases en colegios y en
los jardines de los niños han tenido que
ser canceladas porque la infraestructura
no está adecuada en este país para
funcionar con semejantes temperaturas
también se sigue recomendando que las
personas trabajen desde las casas no
utilicen los transportes públicos ni
tampoco incluso salgan de sus casas
hasta que bajen las temperaturas las
televisiones y los periódicos están
llenos de recomendaciones de cómo
superar cómo incluso alimentarse
mantenerse hidratado durante esta ola de
calor y las recomendaciones médicas esto
es obviamente mantenerse lo más
hidratado posible como los expertos en
cambio climático han advertido que estas
olas de calor serán cada vez más
frecuentes y por ello los gobiernos
deben adoptar medidas urgentes también
el ministro de transporte británico ha
dicho hoy que adaptar la infraestructura
ferroviaria del país por lo menos para
atender esas futuras olas de calor
podría incluso tardar décadas